a three-year-long investigation in the
gambia has recommended former president
yahya jammeh be put on trial for murder
torture and sexual violence
best responsibility for the killing
of both alma mo mane and
the former president seized power in
1994 and for 22 years oversaw a regime
that has been accused of committing
hundreds of human rights abuses
[Music]
in 2017 xiaomi was forced into exile in
equatorial guinea after losing an
election to adama barrow
under president barrow the gambia's
government set up the truth
reconciliation and reparations
commission to probe allegations of jamai
era abuses
the panel heard from hundreds of
witnesses who offer testimony about
alleged human rights violations their
stories were broadcast on radio and tv
for the country to hear
the government now has six months to
decide its next steps we are hoping that
the government that has already given a
commitment that has made a commitment to
implement the recommendations of the
commission will make sure that free and
fair trials are held
right now there are recommendations for
prosecution but
of course they are just recommendations
and
the charges have not charges have not
been preferred against anyone so the
allegations are just that allegations
many at home and abroad hope to see the
former president on trial though he
remains in exile
but gambians weren't the sole targets of
the regime jaya james victims
include over 44 ghanaians who were
massacred they include nigerians they
include senegalese and the thinking is
that if all these countries
got together and helped gambia
to create a court it would also provide
the political
impetus
for
equatorial guinea where gia jammeh is
living
the commission is intended to promote
healing and reconciliation for victims
and survivors but jiame still retains
considerable support in the country
the possibility of his return from exile
was a key election issue earlier this
month
[Music]
and there are concerns his political
supporters could hamper efforts to put
the former leader and his associates on
trial
jammeh has yet to reply to the
commission's findings in the past he's
promised to return to the gambia but
he's been barely seen in the years since
his exile
the report may make him question whether
he would even want to
alexander lurch al jazeera